♪ ♪
>> Mark: "NEWSWEEK" MAGAZINE
IS DELIVERING AN IMPORTANT
WARNING THIS CHRISTMAS SEASON
COME ON SUNDAY "NEWSWEEK"
PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE SAYING THAT
THE AND DONALD TRUMP "STOLE
CHRISTMAS FROM A WHITE
NATIONALISM" SEVERAL WARNED THAT
PHRASES LIKE MERRY CHRISTMAS
HAVE BECOME A DOG WHISTLE
SHOWING SUPPORT FOR WHITES AND
FAILED THE HATRED OF MUSLIMS,
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOW
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOP
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOI
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOT
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NON
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOG
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOE
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOS
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NO
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOG
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOS
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOW
DUPES, ATHEISTS, IMMIGRANTS, NOL
SOON BE A HATEFUL ASSAULT ON
VEGANS EVERYWHERE.
A PSYCHOTHERAPIST, AND SHE JOINS
US, NOW, DO YOU BUY INTO THIS
IDEA THAT MERRY CHRISTMAS IS A
RACIST DOGMATISM?
>> I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
ARTICLE, NOT NECESSARILY WHAT I
BELIEVE, AS A JOURNALIST I DID
RESEARCH INTO THIS.
I THOUGHT, IS THERE ACTUALLY
THIS HAPPENING?
NINE OUT OF EVERY TEN AMERICANS
IN THE UNITED STATES CELEBRATE
HAPPENING IN THE BIPARTISAN
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION COMING OUT
WITH A STUDY YESTERDAY SAYING
THAT ONLY 46% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WHICH IS DOWN FROM THE PERCENT
IN 2013, SO THERE IS A CHANGING
OF THE TIES, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
A WAR ON CHRISTMAS, BUT A CHANGE
OF THE TIES THAT PEOPLE IN
AMERICA SOCIETY ARE BECOMING
JUSTIFIES THIS COMPARISON OF
TRUMP AND ADELE NAZIS.
SO START, THEY BASICALLY SECULAR
LYSED CHRISTMAS, TURN IT INTO A
PAGAN NATURE WORSHIP.
SO IF ANYBODY IS COMPARABLE TO
THE NAZIS.
IT IS THE HIPPIE DIPPY
WORSHIPERS ON DECEMBER 21ST,
ISN'T THAT RIDICULOUS JUST TO
>> I THINK WHAT THE ARTICLE WAS
SUGGESTING WAS THAT TRUMP IS
USING THE LANGUAGE TO
EMBOLDEN --
>> Mark: LANGUAGE LIKE
"MERRY CHRISTMAS?"
>> IT IS NOT JUST SAYING
MERRY CHRISTMAS, HE IS SAYING
THE WAR ON CHRISTMAS HAS ENDED.
AND WHEN YOU SUGGESTED THAT
THERE WAS A WAR ON
CHRISTMAS, AND MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
DEFENSIVE, WHAT PEOPLE FEEL
DEFENSIVE WHEN THEY ARE SAYING
THAT THERE IS A WAR ON CHRISTMAS
THAT THERE IS A WAR ON CHRISTMA
CHRISTMAS.
>> Mark: PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING
MADE TO BE DEFENSIVE WHEN THEY
GO TO THE SHOPPING MALL AND THE
CLERK SAYS "HAPPY HOLIDAYS" AS
IF THERE IS SOMETHING DIRTY
ABOUT SAYING MERRY CHRISTMAS.
>> IT IS INTERESTING THAT YOU
BRING IN THAT, BECAUSE HALF OF
THE PEOPLE POLLED DO NOT CARE
HOW THEY ARE ADDRESSED IN STORES
DURING THE HOLIDAYS.
THEY DO NOT FEEL ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER, WHETHER PEOPLE SAY
MERRY CHRISTMAS OR HAPPY
HOLIDAYS.
SO I THINK AGAIN, THE CULTURE IS
CHANGING AND PEOPLE ARE BECOMING
MUCH MORE OKAY WITH HOW EVERYONE
WANTS TO EXPRESS IN TERMS OF THE
THE LAW CENTER, THE SHAKEDOWN
RACKET, CENTRALLY, ALL VERY RICH
ON IT SHAKING THEIR MONEY AWAY
IN BRITISH COLONIAL TAX SAVINGS,
THE TRACK HATE HER TRACKS
PHRASES " -- HOW COME THE HATE
GROUP TRACKER THINGS HASHTAG
JESUS IS THE REASON OF THE
SEASON IS A HATE PHRASE?
>> THAT IS REALLY INTERESTING, I
DO NOT KNOW WHY.
I REALLY DO NOT.
I THINK AGAIN, THAT TIMES ARE
CHRISTMAS IS A BACKLASH AGAINST
THE POLITICAL MOVEMENT THAT CAME
OUT DURING THE 1990s, SO THE
WAS FROM A PSYCHOTHERAPIST POINT
OF VIEW IS ABOUT BEING INCLUSIVE
INCLUSIVITY, SO WE WANT TO HAVE
MORE ROOM FOR PEOPLE TO EXPRESS
THEMSELVES.
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE TAKE
SOMETHING AWAY.
>> Mark: BUT SOMETHING LIKE
BUSH HAS HIS HAPPY REMEDY AND
THEN ALL OF IT, AND SUDDENLY AT
HIS CHRISTMAS, THE BIG
MAINSTREAM THING THAT HAS TO BE,